foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
is it gonna happen we're going to a
final final round
it all comes out of this
[Music]
[Applause]
the crowd is going wild
[Music]
thank you
all the pressure
final round
oh my God know me bringing it back he
refuses to go down
not just that it's gonna do a ton of
damage go for it
oh my God besides different obviously
though you can't knock out this man out
Jimmy trying put him away the shoulder
out of nowhere Jimmy with the side roll
he's in the bad position now no he's got
the wall
brake Drive
[Music]
here we go he's going in
we've lost the victim anybody's badge
Jimmy
World Tour finals
man yo my God
this guy is crazy
[Music]
almost at the bar meter rage available
Beijing will kill that was so ballsy
final fight around here the winner of
this round will move into top eight of
the technology it all comes out of this
now just building the meter there all
the spring kick stopping that momentum
there's a slide it's like you
oh no standing two his trademark with
punish kept him out here we go full wall
carry but doesn't get the walls flat
lucky for low height
to be unfortunate he does have a slight
life lead here he's gonna have to be
very careful Lauren's gonna have to play
out of his mind if he wants to exercise
his demon oh the sidewalk all this big
oh my gosh he gets the punish one more
hit we'll do it
eliminating away from the tournament oh
my God
and rainbow arson about to take the
tournament candy find a way back into
this holy crap
Arthur for the win right now oh my God
final first day German boy reach that
boy
oh my God bro I'm getting light-headed
[Music]
we have not seen enough of those
no counter hits no shoulders
20 seconds on the clock
pick down the wire and going either way
14 seconds no one ain't good 10 seconds
oh my God rainbow Prodigy seven seconds
five seconds keep watching the ring back
it's not over hard to get it back in
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man
give them to me
listen to the crowd here oh get up oh
Jesus everybody shut the [__] up
[Music]
oh my God
Jesus Christ y'all better clip every
goddamn shot of that back
[Music]
thank you
I'm leaving
very patient looking for an opening oh
down four
goes for the running three down three
with the meter two ounces yeah I think
I'll get it it's gonna be uh thinking
about that rage off Potential from John
ding he's lost quite a few times that
way now from him but Lowe's nice low
probably once again okay
oh and the extension on the combo with
the tattoo as well a pixel away from the
meter there it is and this is not where
you want to be Steve I'm talking about
looking at wall means wow nice confirm
they're not speeding the meter yeah I
would have out of Phoenix range
positioning good punish I love that he's
not using this when you're literally
waiting to get to him
he realized that he wasn't in range John
they could definitely take this because
one launch one counter hit what are we
gonna get here he's using the meter whoa
here we go in wall launch on the
hurricane punish hold up oh no
oh
stop it
oh my God
my God active jumps out of his chair
crazy crazy scenes here in Amsterdam
[Music]
there's no side left oh my God
Steve I'm speechless who's this dude in
who sweats dude almost but I don't even
know who he was but I almost hit him
it's just out of excitement I apologize
you scared me that scared me
all right I'll kind of I'll kind of keep
my arm on you make sure you don't hit
anything but man that last round
okay we're in agreement he was about to
punch me I was about to punch in it's
okay
and me with a slight life Advantage here
oh wow to get out again get off of me
bro
this is what it's like to see God's go
at it I don't want to do this anymore I
don't want to do this anymore
I don't want to do it anymore
that's what that's where the broken
death grip gives you that's why I heard
so fast
oh what's he gonna do oh oh oh
[Applause]
my goodness
[Music]
game of the top eight I know
oh no Perry
okay here we go he's gonna have good up
G has the wall here yeah what kind of
mix-up is he gonna employ okay good job
blocking that laser scraper it looks
like he went for a power pressure he
interrupt turn Steely oh man he's gonna
extend is he gonna get the whole thing
yeah he gets this two-part that's a big
chunk oh he went for the Slime oh my God
it's not going for the mids now all the
side steps here from JD's
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't believe it again oh my God
if you enjoyed the video please leave a
like and make sure to subscribe to
Charter TV for more Tech and content
[Music]
[Applause]